yes well
hello also from my side
um yes I'm Simon I'm working at Kunis
week and I would like to use the
opportunity to hardly invite all of you
to our Amazing Quiz you can win a
PlayStation 5.
and in case you want to know anything
about me or about Cody's wig or about me
at cooneyswick you can usually find me
at our booth
end of advertisement block
what do I want to talk about today I
want to share with you the experiences I
had when I moved into Jax
I've been using pytorch before and
in my experience with Jax there were a
few stumbling blocks which I thought
might be interesting for you to hear
about
so you can make an informed decision if
Jax is the right thing for your use case
and in case I bore you overly much
you can start artifact hunting in my
presentation
example here
to give you a little bit of context
about how I came to use Jax I had the
opportunity to work on a bit of a
research project on a graph neural
network
and I only had a very limited time frame
I need to train multiple models so I
Googled around how can I speed things up
and then I came up uh
came across Jax
and if you have ever encountered any Jax
related material you will know that one
of the key advantages of Jax is speed
um quick side note here a lot of the
examples you find online are
I would argue not ideal in so far as a
lot of the comparisons compare tiny
functions
and that's not really representative of
a deep learning use case actually if you
think about it
therefore I'm very grateful for the
speed comparison by hugging face
and they
benchmarked a Jacks I think actually 10
Jacks based models again
pytorch based models and they reported
speed ups and training time between 20
and 40 percent
I've given you the link down here if
you're interested you can check that out
so that's about the level of speed up I
was expecting as well
um furthermore Jax is a rapidly growing
ecosystem which is currently getting a
lot of attention which makes it very
interesting to have a look at it at
least
it has a familiar numpy-like interface
which I thought makes usage actually
quite easy so what can go wrong
and if you have access to tpus you can
run your code without further
transformation on TPU which also sounded
very handy to me
so I got started on my journey
and I encountered some difficulties but
in order to understand these
difficulties we need to have a look at
it just in time compiler in Jax
um can you give me a brief show of hands
who has some form of understanding how
the just in time compiler injects works
okay
good that yeah then let's discuss this
very briefly
injects making your function just in
time compilable is actually very easy
from your side you have to just add a
decorator
if one of these decorated functions is
called for the first time with a new
object it hasn't seen before so with a
new signature
um the function will be compiled the
signature is the shape and data type of
the input
what happens during compilation is that
your input will be replaced with an
abstract Tracer value and this Tracer
value will be used to translate your
python code into a jackspr expression
I have an example in a moment this
jackspr expression is then
when by the way we're now talking about
the stage out now we have a Jack Sparrow
this is then lowered which means it's
converted into a valid input for the xla
compiler
the xla compiler performs its magic and
makes your code run on the accelerator
of choice so CPU GPU or TPU and then
your code is finally executed after
compilation with your original input
less abstract I apologize for the
stupidity of the example but I had to
fill it on a slide
you can see a very very easy function on
the left hand side here we have an input
we print the input we add plus 1 to the
input three times
and then we're done we return the input
on the right hand side you see the
resulting Jack Spar expression and I
would like to draw your attention to
three things here
first you can see that all of the data
objects we have here ABCD are annotated
with a fixed shape and data type
this means whenever
this means that this jackspr is actually
only valid for this specific combination
of shape and data type
in practice this means we need to
recompile our code whenever we hit a new
combination of input shape and data type
the second thing I would like to draw
your attention to is the print statement
because it's gone
this is the fact because Jax doesn't
allow you for side effects
if you have a Jacks function which you
want to just in time compile you're
moving yourself into the beautiful world
of functional python
last
here for Loop
and you can see that the for Loop is
completely unpacked
Jax wants to concretize your input as
much as possible for easy compilation
now imagine you have for loops and the
number of Loops is dependent on your
input
and this will not work because Jax
wouldn't know how to unpack this how
many statements should there be here
and these are the main caveats you need
to keep in mind when you're working with
jacks
so I've given you the overview here
guarantees only for Pure functions
during just-in-time compilation no
stateful functions
avoid recompilation whenever possible
and the structure of functions pass to
the just-in-time compiler
shouldn't depend on the input value
so these are the challenges
and I want to address
the later two now
what do you do if you have something in
your function that actually needs to
depend on the input value
and here you have three basic choices
first I would recommend checking out the
Jack slacks control flow Primitives
um Lex is basically
underlying the handy numpy interface so
we're moving one layer down
in terms of abstraction
if you can't find anything there
it's in my opinion a valid choice to
also say we've just moved this logic
outside of the Just in Time compiled
part of the function and only just in
time compile the specific thing we need
so remove the logic or my preferred
solution is working with static
arguments
this means
that we declare one of our inputs
to not only the be defined by shape and
data type but also by value
but keep in mind if we make this more
specific we also need to recompile more
often because
now we need to recompile whenever we hit
a different input value as well
talking about recompilation another
thing I want to make you aware of or
I experience is really really useful and
I wish I would have kept in mind earlier
is
padding
if you're working with Jax it's highly
likely that you sooner or later find
yourself in a situation where one of
your model inputs
just has a different shy shape every
time in my instance I was working with
graph neural networks I needed to
dynamically remove edges from the graph
depending on the training batch
and you can imagine how many different
graph
shapes were the result of that
and I tried to run this and I was so
disappointed in Jax because with all the
performance nothing there everything is
horribly slow
and
padding is I think the most elegant
solution to this just bring everything
to one shape if possible
um I'm bringing this up I mean it's kind
of self-evident
but I wish I would have known it
beforehand because fixing this post talk
can be a bit of a pain
enough with complaining about Jax I also
want to make you aware of another great
feature that in my opinion flies a
little bit under the radar in the
marketing materials
which is Jax performs some Jax offers
you a great option to vectorize your
code
um
I've a little running example in the
next couple of slides we have two
vectors Vector A and B each is itself
composed of two other vectors and we
want to compute the element-wise vector
product
easiest solution to this problem
vectorization with a for Loop
so you can see this relatively simple
problem produces this much of a jack
Spar that's also the reason why we're
looking at this specific problem because
anything more interesting would have
exploded on the slide
so advantages this is very
straightforward but compile time is long
performance is not really as efficient
as it could be
and therefore I want to make you aware
of
the map
doing the same thing in basically one
line of code and what is awesome and
feels a little bit like magic about the
vmap
is that it doesn't happen sequentially
anymore
vmap Maps the function the way that all
of the vectorization steps are executed
at the same time which massively
increases your accelerator utilization
which is really cool and thereby
massively reduces runtime
so I think this is an awesome feature
that
should get more attention actually
the only downside is
doing everything at once kind of
consumes a lot of memory
and I ran into this problem multiple
times so do I need to go back to a for
Loop
answer is no I don't
Jax offers you also a map operator which
is again hidden a little bit in the Lex
package
which produces this and it might look
also a little bit complicated but if you
have a look it's in fact only one large
scan function
so this reduces memory consumption by
being strictly sequential again
and has a way better compile time than
actually having this for Loop which
needs to be unpacked in multiple
different functions
only problem with this solution is
it only takes one input argument so I
had to package my two vectors into a
tuple
so the usage is a little bit cumbersome
and
talking about packaging brings me to one
of the other things I realized when
working with Jax
I guess that's more of a functional
programming thing
than a Jacks thing but given that you
don't have any state in your functions
everything needs to be passed around
don't worry your model parameters don't
need to be passed around individually
there's still a container for that
but you might be wondering
about your random numbers for example
injects random number generation is
handled by passing around a key the
random number generator in contrast to
Pi torch doesn't keep track of the
numbers it has already produced so you
need to pass around the key whenever you
need new values
this can be quite cumbersome
and generally speaking every other thing
you want in your model to be kind of
behaving like a state needs to be
manually handled so it's very easy to
get lost in stuff you handle your hand
around lost in parameters
therefore
data classes the solution to most of
Mankind's problems
um
I highly recommend thinking about also
this and if
before getting started what are the
parameters I want to walk want to hand
around
and then package them into Data classes
which also makes refactoring way easier
imagine you're in the fifth layer of a
stack Trace
and you realize oh yeah I need
information that was present in the
context of the first function that
called another function it called
another function it's called another
function so you would need to add the
parameter to each of the functions in
between
so this can be very conveniently solved
with using data classes
only thing is you need to register data
classes
again I recommend checking out this very
helpful Flex utility here
that very much simplifies this process
this slide is a bit of a general
collection of memory issues I
encountered I tried to fit all of this a
little bit more neatly together
but I couldn't so here's the laundry
list I'm sorry
you need to know that Jax allocates 90
of GPU memory
whenever you initialize the first Jax
object
and when I got started I found this
Behavior a little bit annoying so I
turned that off so I can see what's
actually taking up all my GPU space
and then I realized oh I can't fit my
model on my GPU
and then I turned it back on again and I
realized that there's a huge difference
in terms of efficiency in memory usage
if you pre-allocate
by extension
if your model only narrowly doesn't fit
on a GPU it makes sense to increase this
share of 90 percent
maybe it fits I would give this a try
also just in time compiled functions
take up way less space in memory so when
you find yourself debugging that's
something to keep in mind don't despair
if your function suddenly breaks your
GPU
if it's just compiled it might very well
fit
and a little bit random but
I spend so much time on this I want to
at least mention it
if you save a GPU if you save an array
to disk it will try when you load it
back in it will try to go to the same
GPU from where you saved it which is a
little bit of an annoying Behavior so
just so you don't spend two hours on
trying to figure out why
stuff that fit before doesn't fit
anymore
that's it from the technical side of
things another thing I want to address
is General project maturity how does
that feel when you're using Jax for the
first time
Jax is rapidly growing
which also
means that not everything is already
there yet that you might be needing
I also learned that the hardware you
really need to make sure that if you
have a very specific use case in mind
where efficiency is Paramount that
what's there is actually implemented to
the same degree of efficiency in my case
I needed to have an optimized message
passing algorithm I only checked and
giraffe provides some form of message
passing
and then I wanted to scale up from my
toy example and I realized
it just doesn't fit it's not there
okay I guess I need to do this myself
let's get started with sparse matrices
well sparse matrices are kind of there
but not entirely yet not every feature
that I would have needed so
if you consider making the transition to
Jax I would really advise you to make
sure that everything is there that you
need
generally though the development is
quite rapid in the six months project
I've been working on I could basically
watch the sparse Matrix Matrix Matrix
capabilities of Jax grow so
if something isn't there yet doesn't
mean that it will never be there give it
two weeks it might very well have
appeared
um
last thing I want to address is my
experience with support and examples
when using Jax because that's one of the
key advantages if you're using one of
the two big players in deep learning
everything has been done before it's
easy to get examples
and with Jax my experience was that
everything
can be found
you just you should just take more time
finding it can
can take a little bit longer can be a
little bit more hidden
generally speaking
um
I also made quite good experiences with
the stack Overflow and flex so there
seems to be sufficient support there
can only recommend that in summary
Jax offers some great features such as
very efficient just in time compilation
and vectorization
but using Jax introduces a set of
restrictions which which you need to
keep in mind and which might very well
force you to implement things
differently that
your intuition would have been to
implement them
also anticipate more the anticipator
spent more time when you're Googling for
a problem
and
that's it I think I might have been too
early
thank you so much Simon for sharing your
insights on working with the Jacks so we
received a couple of questions and I
will start with the first one can Jack's
work with distributed computing for
example distributed model training
yes it can
to have sound
okay yes it can I personally haven't
used it
but I know that the functionality is
there
if you check out the
padding functionality the link is in the
slides that's also meant to work on
distributed data sets
explain what exactly you mean with
padding oh okay
sorry I thought yeah anyway by padding I
meant
that you might be running into a
situation where something is not as big
as another thing one area not the same
size as another area smaller usually
and you just add stuff to fill that
array up to the same size
in my instance talking about graphs in
the net edges in a network
I added self edges to an artificial
garbage note which was not corrected
connected to the remainder of the
network
so that the network has a fixed number
of edges
I hope this makes it clearer
for clarifying
so how did you do the input padding
the input
yeah I think that's what I just
explained in my instance it was about
graph so it was relatively easy
to just add artificial edges which were
only connected to one node which I
introduced but not connected to the
remainder of the network and then these
were self edges only connecting the node
2 itself so the information from this
fake note wouldn't
um diffuse into my real Network
any thoughts on Jax versus Pi torch for
model prototyping why use Jacks for
graph neural Nets
um for prototyping
I think that's a little bit of a hard
question because most people are already
experienced in using pytorch and as I
said the switch to Jax necessitates some
adjustment period so you're probably
faster prototyping in something that you
already know
um
so I guess that's user dependence
and the remainder of that question was
so why use Jax for graph neural Nets
I think you yeah I use
I used it because I really wanted to run
as many experiments as possible and I
thought everything's there that I need
so why not use that sweet sweet speed up
paddable with onnx conversion
I'm really sorry I don't know
okay so we will see
and then also a question maybe it's
about elaborating there's a little
further how is the Jax development
experience is there an eager mode
development experience
how you work as a developer
maybe maybe that's a that's a
misunderstanding I'm not a Jax developer
I'm a user I'm talking from Strictly
from a user's perspective
but with all the I've been in contact
with Developers
you mentioned that you
got
a very
oh and that you like features were
flying in within like two weeks so maybe
the question is a little bit it feels
very responsive still maybe it's because
it's still growing very much
and you can definitely feel that
deepmind is putting quite some resources
into Jax so that feels very responsive
if you ask for something
you might get it
that's very nice to hear a very
responsive community
so this question is what was your use
case using Jax
I wanted to I found a very interesting
graph neural network model and I wanted
to re-implement that and then run
multiple experiments with it
in case you're interested in the model
itself I recommend Googling for neural
Bellman Ford networks for link
prediction and knowledge graphs
hope that answers that
thank you so much I hope it does if not
I guess you're still around yes people
can always you can find me close to a
Playstation
all right perfect so another question
how much of the performance advantages
comes from the jit compilation
everything
um no seriously if you run the functions
without the jit compilation
I think they're actually slower than
pytorch oh sorry there seems to be
somewhat objecting
oh oh a question well I can just give
you the mic and then you can
hi I wanted to ask about uh how does Jax
compare to like a number and it's Jude
compiler because both tools kind of do
jit compilation so I wanted to know if
you had any experience comparing those
two
unfortunately no I have played around
with number but never to the same degree
that I use Jax so I don't feel qualified
to give you a definite answer on that
um but I
when I looked up numbers for this talk I
stumbled across a comparison where
somebody achieved comparable results on
CPU with number and Jacks
I mean with Jax you can then go on to
move to GPU or TPU which I'm not sure if
number actually supports that
GPU yes
so number supports compiling to GPU
Nvidia gpus actually only so okay I
wasn't aware yeah but no tpus so that's
kind of Google proprietary I think
oh all the questions are gone now
interesting
um oh back again okay
um
so I think we have time to actually
answer all those nice questions and
there is another one on debugging how is
the model debugging experience in Jax
I would say that very much depends if
you already have put a nice should
compile around everything and then
you start to get arrows with only one
specific batch it can feel a little bit
opaque because what is if it the
function is already just in time
compiled you can't debug in it with the
usual Ides
so then you find yourself in a situation
where you try to decipher the error
message you're getting
which can feel a little bit frustrating
at times
I would definitely recommend
a having kind of a hard test data set to
play around with
Maybe
introduce some of the errors yourself
that you want to debug into your test
data set and B I found it very helpful
to use
um very specific
shapes
for things
for example limit the input to let's say
be an array with only 13 rows and then
the linear layer has 27 so definitely
numbers that you can't get by accident
so that helps you to better find um
where you are in the trace because there
are shapes printed out
in the error messages
thank you
so maybe less on to onto prototyping but
generally the benefit s of using Jax
versus the big players
in general I find the offering very
attractive that you can also run it on
TPU just gives you another option if you
don't if you want to move away from
Nvidia which I think is something worth
considering
um
speed
is really there to my knowledge
you can also just in time compile in pi
torch but it's more meant for deployment
in Jax you can already get these speed
UPS during training which is really nice
and
I'm in case you didn't notice I'm kind
of in love with the vectorization option
makes development very easy and the
result is super efficient
very nice so last question so we stay on
time is the person that answers the
Jacks stack Overflow question you
no it's not me I wish it was me if I
ever make it to that level of knowledge
about Jax I will heavily Pat myself on
the shoulder
uh no that's um
can I call out names
I'm sorry if I butcher his name now Jake
thunderplas or someone
to my knowledge he's living in
Washington also working for Google
and he seems to single-handedly
take care of all Jax related question on
stack overflow
which is very impressive in my opinion
wow big shout out to Washington
so Simon thank you so much for your
interesting talk
um
and for sharing your knowledge about Jax
with us
thanks
[Applause]